una vez más en la polémica recae sobre
la figura del rapero y diseñador kanye
West en esta ocasión a por estos
comentarios de corte neonazi
ng
algo que además de violentar a la
comunidad judía y ganarle un aluvión de
críticas ha vetado al conocido como ye
de Twitter Solo dos meses después de que
le devolvieran la cuenta ya que ni
siquiera el propietario y
multimillonario y lo más firme defensor
de lo que denomina libertad de expresión
ha podido ignorar
Esto está bien
esto no está bien Lo hice lo mejor que
pude a pesar de eso volvió a violar
nuestra Norma contra la incitación de
violencia la cuenta será suspendida
Esta no es la primera vez que el famoso
artista se ve envuelto en uno de estos
escándalos tanto por sus comentarios
antisemitas en el pasado motivo por el
que le habían bloqueado la cuenta como
para arremeter contra otras celebridades
incluso Víctimas de violencia fue el
caso de George Floyd el hombre
afroamericano que murió luego que un
policía sostuviera su rodilla sobre su
cuello durante casi 9 minutos y sobre el
que ya sugirió que podría haber muerto
por el uso del fentanilo declaraciones
que le han puesto en el centro de las
críticas y le han hecho perder contratos
multimillonarios como el de Adidas o
valenciaga
ya no tengo manager porque no puedo ser
manejado algo que algunos han abordado
con humor desde las redes
[Música]
en la cabeza de kanye West él es así soy
un hombre blanco de 35 años de edad pero
que genera mucha preocupación por los
valores que promociona el músico uno de
los más escucha